soon you'll be able to make all those
pocket monsters you caught on bus fight
for your amusement I'm Dave and welcome
to our poker battle news updates Pokemon
go recently added a buddy system but
that may not be the only new feature
coming to widely popular mobile game
pokemon company CEO tsunekazu ishihara
told the Wall Street Journal that
niantic labs is taking its time
releasing new features for the game so
as to not overwhelm newcomers battling
is a category that we do best a pokemon
after all it's important to really
carefully consider any feature that may
increase the difficulty and raise the
barrier to entry for more casual users
the trading system was also mentioned in
the report but issue harrods not comment
on this specifically in July an antic
lab CEO John Hanke confirmed that a
trading system was on the way we did not
share any information as to when it
might be released or how it would work
similarly we don't know much about how a
battle system for Pokemon go might play
out or when it would arrive Pokemon go
most fair has been in the works for a
long time report to early tests are
promising but there's still much work to
be done nyan takes our cake bhargava
said that multiplayer aspect is still
something we're exploring for trying to
figure out what's the best way to do
that so far we've learned that
multiplayer battles are a lot of fun
when two people from different teams
show up at rival gym if they can
elaborate and both have their Pokemon to
point about at the same time they can
take down a stronger gym faster but
we're trying our best to rethink what
that experience should be what the real
world Pokemon experience should be like
obviously we're learning from ingress
but it's going to be a pretty different
game we have a vision for Pokemon we're
going to execute on it but we're going
to learn based on what the community
reaction is so other features would you
like to see in Pokemon go let us know in
the comment section below or find me on
Twitter at a regular Dave and for
everything Pokemon make sure you
subscribe to gamespot